[Musique]
rétrospectivement on s'était un peu
culotté quand même oser dire aux gens
sortez de chez vous avec vos voir vos
instruments de musique tout simplement
votre vous-même
s'étaient risqués que personne ne
réponde et d'ailleurs ce fut pour moi un
des grands traque de ma vie je craignais
que ce soit un bide les gens allait-il
répondre à notre appel et finalement oui
d'abord timidement puis ensuite avec
ardeur et ferveur comme ces images le
montrent certains artistes avaient pris
des initiatives parallèles par exemple
jacques higelin avait à travers la ville
vous parler tu auras camion déployer
rassembler autour de lui des musiciens
amateurs
[Musique]
on
c'est la première fois que le petit
village de fresne sur loire organise une
fête de la musique les enfants de la
chorale s'en donnent à coeur joie au
coucher du soleil
[Musique]
partout à travers le pays dans les
quartiers dans les gares dans les
villages dans les petites villes c'est
ça qui est le plus touchant le plus
émouvant et bravo à la télévision qui a
capté ces images dans un village ce qui
me touche le plus qui nous réjouit le
plus de pensée que au même moment à
travers tout le pays y compris dans des
endroits qui paraissent éloignées le
coeur de la musique bat venir vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point plusieurs
semaines avancent parfois les gens se
préparent des musiciens des habitants
changent même l'alluré du village où la
lueur de la petite ville le reçoit
chaque année des des affiches des
documents des petits films c'est ça qui
est le plus vous êtes le plus émouvant
[Musique]
oh
la fête a commencé dès ce matin dans la
rue en jonglant on joue on déclame et on
chante 85 sera l'année de la musique et
hatem est proclamée capitale européenne
de la culture par les chefs d'état grecs
et français est une idée que nous allons
inventer avec la ministre mercouri peu
chaque année une ville soit choisie
comme capitale de l'europe et surtout il
y avait cette volonté qui était la nôtre
de propager ces événements à travers
l'europe pour eux c'était la première
donc comme pour nous c'était le début
encore hésitant mais dans d'autres pays
d'europe sauf immédiatement un grand
succès je pense notamment à berlin
aujourd'hui c'est le plus grand festival
de musique du monde
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
tous ne sont pas des génies puisque
l'idée c'est que chacun apporte ce qu'il
a en lui son talent son énergie son
imagination quand vous imaginez que dans
quelques heures
aux etats unis c'est dans 100 villes
américaines notamment new york en chine
dans 300 villes chinoises et en europe
c'est l'évidence berlin madrid partout à
travers le monde parce que nous voulions
créer une sorte de grande chaîne de
l'amitié entre les amoureux de la
musique du gros l'antienne 23h enfin il
ne pleut plus grand jeu les parapluies
et on sent les briquets à la république
ils sont venus en foule pour écouter joe
cocker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
je n'ai pas à arbitrer ou à choisir
d'ailleurs puisque vous évoquez quelques
vedettes je me souviens là nous sommes à
quelques pas du lycée à la culture qui
ne souvient qu'un soir
stevie wonder est venu nous rendre
visite ou les rolling stones ou bien
d'autres vedettes c'est vrai et
française aussi mais en même temps
c'était bien parce qu'ils apportaient
leur soutien de grands professionnels un
événement qui fait appel d'abord aux
jeunes aux jeunes femmes acteurs aux
jeunes professionnels
brigitte macron se déhanche
son mari se montre plus réservé
je suis militant de la diversité des
musiques rock rap musique traditionnelle
musique classique électro je suis
beaucoup bagarré avec d'autres pour
faire reconnaître pleinement l'un
musique techno qui était à un moment
diaboliser excommunié d'où d'ailleurs la
création de la techno parade qui aura
lieu à nouveau cette année en septembre
prochain alors j'étais vraiment heureux
et fier en même temps que le président
ait choisi de dédier cette fête de la
musique à la musique techno et une
ambiance extraordinaire une remarquable
interprète et musicien
les pisse-vinaigre
sont ils armés
comme les sceptiques aussi son d'une
armée puisse vinaigre
ne peuvent pas ne pas déverser leur bile
c'est normal c'est partie du set unis et
d'une marque du succès c'est parce que
nous sommes dans la bonne voie que tout
à coup se dresse
mauvais coucheurs et qu'ils aillent
faire dodo
[Musique]